what percent probability would you
currently place
on the hypothesis that covered 19 league
from the
wuhan institute of virology so i
maintain
a flow chart of all the possible
explanations
and it doesn't break down exactly that
way
the likelihood that it emerged from a
lab is very very high
if it emerged from a lab the likelihood
that the lab was the wuhan institute
is very very high the
there are multiple different kinds of
evidence that point to the lab
and there is literally no evidence that
points to nature
either the evidence points nowhere or it
points to the lab and the lab could mean
any lab
but geographically obviously the labs in
wuhan are the most likely and the lab
that was most directly involved with
research on
viruses that look like cove that look
like stars cov2
is obviously the place that one would
start
but i would say the likelihood that this
virus
came from a lab is well above 95
we can talk about the question of could
a virus have been brought into the lab
and escape from there without being
modified that's also
possible but it doesn't explain any of
the anomalies
in the genome of sarsko v2
um could it have been delivered from
another lab could wuhan be a distraction
um in order that we would connect the
dots in the wrong way
that's conceivable i currently have that
below one percent on my flow chart but i
have a very dark
thought that somebody would would do
that almost as a
a political attack on china well it
depends
i don't even think that's one
possibility
sometimes when eric and i talk about
these issues we will
generate a scenario just to prove that
something could
could live in that space right it's a
placeholder for whatever
may actually have happened and so it
doesn't have to have been
an attack on china that's certainly one
possibility
but i would point out if you can predict
the future in some unusual way
better than others you can print money
right that's what
markets that allow you to bet for or
against uh
virtually any sector allow you to do so
you can imagine a
simply amoral person or entity
generating a pandemic attempting to
cover their tracks
because it would allow them to bet
against things like
you know cruise ships air travel
whatever it is and bet in favor of i
don't know
uh sanitizing gel
and whatever else you would do so
am i saying that i think somebody did
that no i really don't think it happened
we've seen
zero evidence that this was
intentionally released
however were it to have been
intentionally released by somebody who
did not know
did not want it known where it had come
from
releasing it into wuhan would be one way
to cover their tracks so
we have to leave the possibility
formally open but acknowledge there's no
evidence so
and the probability therefore is law i
tend to believe
maybe this is the optimistic nature that
i have that
people who are competent enough to do
the kind of thing we just described
are not going to do that because it
requires
a certain kind of i don't want to use
the word evil but whatever word you want
to use to describe the kind of
uh this regard for human life required
to do that
you're just that that that's just not
going to be coupled
with competence i feel like there's a
trade-off chart
where competence on one axis and evil is
on the other
and the more evil you become the the
the crappier you are at doing great
engineering scientific work required
to deliver weapons of different kinds
whether it's bioweapons or nuclear
weapons and all those kinds of things
that seems to be the lessons i i take
from history but that doesn't
necessarily mean that's
what's going to be happening in the
future
but to stick on the lab league idea
because the flow chart is probably huge
here because there's a lot of
fascinating
possibilities one question i want to ask
is what would evidence for natural
origins look like
so one piece of evidence
for natural origins is um that
it has happened in the past
that that viruses have jumped
oh they do jump they so like that's one
like
that's possible to have happened you
know
so that that's a sort of like a
historical evidence like okay
well it's possible that it have it's not
it's not evidence of the kind you think
it is it's a justification
for a presumption right right so the
presumption
upon discovering a new virus circulating
is certainly that it came from nature
right the problem is the presumption
evaporates in the face of evidence or at
least it logically should
and it didn't in this case it was
maintained by people who
privately in their emails acknowledged
that they had
grave doubts about the natural origin of
of this virus
is there some other piece of evidence
that we could
look for and see that would say
this increases the probability that it's
natural origins
yeah in fact there is evidence you know
i always worry that somebody is going to
make up some evidence in order to
reverse the flow
well let's say i am a lot of incentive
for that actually there's a huge amount
of incentive on the other hand
why didn't the powers that be the powers
that lied to us about weapons of mass
destruction in iraq why didn't they ever
fake
weapons of mass destruction in iraq
whatever force it is
i hope that force is here too and so
whatever evidence we find is real
it's the confidence thing i'm talking
about but okay go ahead sorry
well we can get back to that but i would
say yeah the the
giant piece of evidence that will shift
the probabilities in the other direction
is the discovery of either a human
population
in which the virus circulated prior to
showing up in
wuhan that would explain where the virus
learned all of the tricks that it knew
instantly upon spreading from wuhan so
that would do it or an animal population
in which an ancestor epidemic can be
found
in which the virus learned this before
jumping to humans but i'd point out in
that
second case you would certainly expect
to see
a great deal of evolution in the early
epidemic which we don't see
so there almost has to be a human
population somewhere else that had the
virus circulator an ancestor of the
virus that we first saw in wuhan
circulating and it has to have gotten
very sophisticated in that prior
epidemic
before hitting wuhan in order to explain
the total lack of evolution
and extremely effective virus that
emerged
uh at the end of 2019. so you don't
believe in the magic of evolution to
spring up with all the tricks already
there like everybody who doesn't have
the tricks they die
quickly and then you just have this
beautiful virus that comes in with a
spike protein and the
and the through mutation uh and
selection
just do like the ones that succeed
and succeed big are the ones that are
going to just spring into life with the
tricks
well no that's that's called a hopeful
monster
and hopeful monsters don't work it's too
the job of
becoming a new pandemic virus is too
difficult
it involves two very difficult steps and
they both have to work one
is the ability to infect a person and
spread in their tissues
sufficient to make an infection and the
other is to jump between
individuals at a sufficient rate that it
doesn't go extinct for one reason or
another
those are both very difficult jobs they
require as you describe
selection and the point is selection
would leave
a mark we would see evidence that it
animals are humans
both right and you see this evolutionary
trace of uh
of the virus gathering the tricks up
yeah you would see the virus
you would see the clumsy virus get
better and better and yes i am a full
believer in the power of that process
in fact i believe it uh what i know
from studying the process is that it is
much more powerful than most people
imagine that what we teach
in the evolution 101 textbook is too
clumsy a process to do
what we see it doing and that actually
people should increase their expectation
of the rapidity with which that process
can produce
just jaw-dropping adaptations that said
we just don't see evidence that it
happened here which doesn't mean it
doesn't exist
but it means in spite of immense
pressure to find it somewhere
there's been no hint which probably
means it took place
inside of a laboratory so inside the
laboratory
gain a function of research on viruses
and i believe
most of that kind of research is doing
this exact thing that you're
referring to which is accelerated
evolution and just watching evolution do
its thing and a bunch of viruses
and seeing what kind of tricks get
developed
the other method is uh
engineering viruses so
manually adding on the tricks
what which do you think we should be
thinking about here
so mind you i learned what i know in the
aftermath of this pandemic
emerging i started studying the question
and i would say
based on the content of the genome and
other evidence
in publications from the various labs
that were involved in
in generating this technology
a couple of things seem likely this
sars kovi ii does not appear to be
entirely the result
of either a splicing process
or serial passaging it it appears to
have both
things in its past or it's at least
highly likely that it does
so for example the fern cleavage site
looks very much like it
uh was added in to the virus and it was
known that that would increase its
infectivity
in humans and increase its tropism
the virus
appears to be excellent at spreading
in humans and minks and ferrets
now minks and ferrets are very closely
related to each other and ferrets are
very likely to have been used in a
serial passage experiment the reason
being
that they have an ac2 receptor that
looks very much like the human ac2
receptor and so
were you going to passage the virus or
its ancestor
through an animal in order to increase
its infectivity in humans which would
have been necessary
ferrets would have been very likely it
is also quite likely that humanized mice
were utilized and it is possible that
human airway tissue
was utilized i think it is vital that we
find out
what the protocols were if this came
from the wuhan institute
we need to know it and we need to know
what the protocols were exactly
because they will actually give us some
tools that would be useful
in fighting sars kovi v2 and hopefully
driving it to extinction which ought to
be our priority
it is a it's a priority that does not it
is not apparent from our behavior
but it really is uh it should be our
objective if we understood where our
interests lie
we would be much more focused on it
but those protocols would tell us a
great deal if it wasn't the wuhan
institute we need to know that
if it was nature we need to know that
and if it was some other laboratory we
need to figure out
who what and where so that we can
determine what is
what we can determine about about what
was done you're opening up
my mind about why we should investigate
why we should know the truth
of the origins of this virus so for me
personally let me just tell
the story of my own kind of journey
when i first started looking into the
lab leak hypothesis
what became terrifying to me and
important to unders
understand and obvious is the
sort of like sam harris way of thinking
which is
it's obvious that a lab leak of a deadly
virus will eventually happen
my mind was it doesn't even matter
if it happened in this case it's obvious
it's going to
happen in the future so why the hell are
we not freaking out about this
and kova 19 is not even that deadly
relative to the possible future viruses
it's this the way i disagree with sam on
this but he thinks about this way about
agi as well
about artificial intelligence it's a
different discussion i think but with
viruses it seems like something that
could happen on the scale of
years maybe a few decades agi is
a little bit farther out for me but it
seemed the terrifying thing it seemed
obvious that this will happen very soon
for a much deadlier virus as we get
better and better
at both engineering viruses and doing
this kind of evolutionary
driven research gain of function
research okay
but then you started speaking out about
this as well but
also started to say no no we should
hurry up and figure out the origins now
because it will help us figure out how
to actually
respond to this particular virus how to
treat this particular virus
what is in terms of vaccines in terms of
antiviral drugs in terms of just
and although the the
the number of responses we should have
okay
i still am much more freaking out about
the future
maybe you can break that apart a little
bit
which are you most um
focused on now which
are you most freaking out about now in
terms of the importance of figuring out
the origins of this virus
i am most freaking out about both of
them
because they're both really important
and you know we can put bounds on this
let me say first this is a perfect test
case for the theory of close calls
because as much as
covet is a disaster it is also a close
call from which we can learn much
you are absolutely right if we keep
playing this game in the lab
if we are not if we are especially if we
do it under pressure
and when we are told that a virus is
going to leap from nature any day
and that the more we know the better
we'll be able to fight it we're going to
create the disaster
all the sooner so yes that should be
an absolute focus the fact that there
were people saying that this was
dangerous back in 2015 ought to tell us
something the fact that the system
bypassed a ban
and offshored the work to china ought to
tell us this is not a chinese failure
this is a failure of something
larger and harder to see
but i also think that there's a there's
a
clock ticking with respect to sars cov2
and covid the disease that it creates
and that has to do with whether or not
we are stuck with it permanently
so if you think about the cost to
humanity of being stuck with influenza
it's an immense cost year after year and
we just stopped thinking about it
because it's there
some years you get the flu most years
you don't maybe you get the vaccine to
prevent it maybe the vaccine isn't
particularly well targeted
but imagine just simply doubling that
cost
imagine we get stuck with sars kov2 and
its descendants
going forward and that it just settles
in and becomes a fact of
modern human life that would be a
disaster right the number of people we
will ultimately lose is incalculable
the amount of suffering that will be
caused is incalculable the loss of
well-being and wealth incalculable so
that ought to be a very high priority
driving this extinct before it becomes
permanent
and the ability to drive extinct goes
down
the longer we delay effective responses
to the extent that we let it have this
very large canvas
large numbers of people who have the
disease in which
mutation and selection can result in
adaptation that we will not be able to
counter
the greater its ability to figure out
features of our immune system and use
them
uh to its advantage so i'm feeling the
pressure
of driving it extinct i believe we could
have driven it extinct
six months ago and we didn't do it
because of very mundane concerns among a
small number of people and i'm not
alleging that they were
brazen about um
or that they were callous about deaths
that would be caused
i have the sense that they were working
from a kind of autopilot
in which you you know let's say you're
in some kind of a corporation a
pharmaceutical corporation
you have a portfolio of
therapies that in the context of a
pandemic might be very lucrative
those therapies have competitors you of
course want to position your product so
that it
succeeds and the competitors don't and
lo and behold at some point
through means that i think those of us
on the outside can't really
intuit you end up saying things about
competing therapies that work
better and much more safely than the
ones you're selling
that aren't true and do cause people to
die in large numbers
um but it you know it's some kind of
autopilot at least part of it is
so the there's a complicated coupling of
the autopilot
of uh institutions
companies governments and then there's
also the
geopolitical game theory thing going on
where you want to keep secrets it's the
chernobyl thing where
if you messed up there's a
big incentive i think to hide the fact
that you messed up
so how do we fix this and what's more
important to fix
the autopilot which is the response
that we often criticize about our
institutions
especially the leaders in those
institutions anthony fauci and so on
uh some of the members of the scientific
community
and the second part is the
the game with china of hiding the
information
in terms of on the fight between nations
well in our live streams on darkhorse
heather and i have been talking from the
beginning
about the fact that although yes what
happens
began in china it very much looks like a
failure of the international scientific
community
and that's frightening but it's also
hopeful in the sense
that actually if we did the right thing
now we're not navigating
a puzzle about chinese responsibility
we're
navigating a question of collective
responsibility for something that has
been terribly costly to all of us
so that's not a very happy process
but as you point out what's at stake is
in large measure at the very least
the strong possibility this will happen
again and that at some point it will be
far worse so you know just as
a person that does not learn the lessons
of their own
errors doesn't get smarter and they
remain in danger
we collectively humanity has to say well
there sure is a lot of evidence that
suggests that this is a self-inflicted
wound
when you have done something that has
caused a massive self-inflected
wound self-inflicted wound it makes
sense
to dwell on it exactly to the point that
you have learned the lesson that makes
it
very very unlikely that something
similar will happen again
i think this is a good place to kind of
ask you to do almost like a thought
experiment
or to steal man
the argument against the lab leak
hypothesis
so if you were to
argue uh you know you said 95
chance that it the virus leaked from a
lab
there's a bunch of ways i think you can
argue
that even talking about it
is uh bad for the world
so i if i just put something on the
table
it's to say that um
for one it would be racism versus
chinese people
that talking about that a leak from a
lab there's a kind of
immediate kind of blame and it can
spiral down
into this idea that's somehow the people
are responsible for the virus and
this kind of thing is it possible for
you to come up with other
steel man arguments against
talking or against the possibility of
the lab leak hypothesis
well so i think steel manning is a tool
that is extremely valuable but it's also
possible to abuse it i think that you
can only steal man a good faith argument
and the problem is we now know that we
have not been engaged
in opponents who were wielding good
faith arguments because privately
their emails reflect their own doubts
and what they were doing publicly was
actually
a punishment a public punishment for
those of us who spoke up
with i think the purpose of either
backing us down or more likely
warning others not to engage in the same
kind of behavior and
obviously for people like you and me who
regard science as
our likely best hope for navigating
difficult waters shutting down people
who are using those tools
honorably is itself dishonorable
so i i don't really i don't feel that it
is
i don't feel that there's anything to
steal man and i also think
that you know immediately at the point
of the world suddenly with
no new evidence on the table switched
years with respect to the lab leak
you know at the point that nicolas wade
had published his article and suddenly
the world was going to admit
that this was at least a possibility if
not a likelihood
we got to see something of the
rationalization process that had taken
place
inside the institutional world and it
very definitely involved the claim
that what was being avoided was the
targeting
of chinese scientists
and my point would be i don't want to
see the targeting of anyone
i don't want to see racism of any kind
on the other hand
once you create license to lie
in order to protect individuals
when the world has a stake in knowing
what happened
then it is inevitable that that process
that license to lie
will be used by the thing that captures
institutions for its own purposes
so my sense is it may be very
unfortunate
if the story of what happened here can
be
used against uh chinese people
that would be very unfortunate and as i
think i mentioned
heather and i have taken great pains to
point out that this doesn't look like a
chinese failure it looks like a failure
of the international scientific
community so
i think it is important to broadcast
that message along
with the analysis of the evidence but no
matter what happened we have a right to
know
and um i frankly do not take the
institutional layer at its word
that its motivations are honorable and
that it was protecting
you know good hearted scientists at the
expense of the world that that
explanation does not add up well this is
a very interesting question
about whether it's ever okay to lie
at the institutional layer to
protect the populace
i think both you and i are probably on
the same
have the same sense that it's a slippery
slope
even if it's an effective mechanism in
the short term in the long term
is going to be destructive this happened
with masks
this happened with other things if you
look at just history pandemics
there is there's an idea that panic
is destructive amongst the populace so
you
you want to construct a narrative
whether it's a lie or not
to minimize panic
but you're suggesting that almost in all
cases
and i think that was the lesson from
the the pandemic in the early 20th
century that
lying creates distrust and distrust
in the institutions is ultimately
destructive
that's your sense that lying is not okay
well
okay you know there are obviously places
where
complete transparency is not a good idea
right to the extent that you
broadcast a technology that allows one
individual to hold the world hostage
right obviously you've got a something
to be navigated but
in general i don't believe that the
scientific system
should be lying to us
in the case of this particular lie
the idea that the well-being of chinese
scientists outweighs the well-being of
the world
is preposterous yeah right as you as you
point out
one thing that rests on this question is
whether we continue to do this kind of
research
going forward and the scientists in
question all of them american
chinese all of them were pushing the
idea that the risk of a
zoonotic spillover event causing a major
and highly destructive pandemic was so
great
that we had to risk this now if they
themselves have caused it
and if they are wrong as i believe they
are about the likelihood
of a major world pandemic spilling out
of nature in the way that they uh
wrote into their grant applications then
the danger is you know the call is
coming from inside the house
and we have to look at that and
yes whatever we have to do to protect
scientists from retribution we should do
but we cannot protecting them by lying
to the world
and even worse by
demonizing people like
me like josh rogan
like yuri dagon the entire drastic group
on
twitter by demonizing us for simply
following the evidence
is to set a terrible precedent right
you're demonizing people for using the
scientific method to evaluate evidence
that is available to us in the world
what a terrible crime it is
to teach that lesson right thou shalt
not use scientific tools
no i'm sorry whatever your license to
lie is it doesn't extend to that
yeah i've seen the the attacks on you
the pressure on you
has a very important effect on
thousands of world-class biologists
actually so at mit colleagues of mine
people i know
there's a slight pressure to not
be allowed to uh one speak publicly
and to actually think
like to even think about these ideas it
sounds kind of ridiculous but just the
in the in the privacy of your own home
to to read things
to to think it's many people
many world-class biologists that i know
will just avoid looking at the data
there's not even that many people that
are publicly opposing gain of function
research
they they're they're also like it's not
worth it
it's not worth the battle and there's
many people that kind of argue that
those battles should be fought in
private
in uh um you know with colleagues in the
um
in the privacy of the scientific
community that the public is somehow not
maybe intelligent enough to be able to
deal with the the complexities of this
kind of discussion
i don't know but the final result is
combined with the bullying of you
and uh all the different pressures in
the academic institutions is that
it's just people are self-censoring and
silencing themselves
and silencing the most important thing
which is the power of their brains
like these people are brilliant
and the fact that they're not utilizing
their brain to come up with solutions
outside of the conformist line of
thinking
is tragic well it is i also think
that it we have to look at it and
understand it for what it is
for one thing it's kind of a cryptic
totalitarianism
somehow people's sense of what they're
allowed to think about talk about
discuss
is causing them to self-censor and i can
tell you it's causing many of them to
rationalize which is even worse they are
blinding themselves to what they can
see but it is also the case i believe
that what you're describing about what
people said and a great many
people understood that the lab leak
hypothesis could not be taken off the
table
but they didn't say so publicly and i
think
that their discussions with each other
about why they did not say what they
understood
that's what capture sounds like on the
inside
i don't know exactly what force captured
the institutions
i don't think anybody knows for sure out
here in public
i don't even know that it wasn't just
simply a process but
you have these institutions they are
behaving
towards a kind of somatic obligation
they have
lost sight of what they were built to
accomplish
and on the inside the way they avoid
going back to their original mission is
to say things
to themselves like the public can't have
this discussion it can't be trusted with
it yes we need to be able to talk about
this but it has to be private whatever
it is they say to themselves that is
what capture sounds like on the inside
it's
a institutional rationalization
mechanism
and it's very very deadly and at the
point you go from
lab leak to repurposed drugs you can see
that it's very deadly
in a very direct way yeah i see this on
in my field of with uh
things like autonomous weapon systems
people in ai
do not talk about the use of ai in
weapon systems
they they kind of avoid the idea that
ai's use them in the military
it's kind of funny there is there's this
like kind of discomfort and they're like
they all hurry like uh you know like
something scary happens and a bunch of
sheep kind of like run a run away that's
what it looks like
and it i don't even know what to do
about it because and then i feel
this natural pull every time i bring up
autonomous weapon systems to go along
with the sheep
there's a natural kind of pull towards
that direction because it's like what
can i do
as one person now there's currently
nothing
destructive happening with autonomous
weapons systems so we're in like in the
early days
of this race that in 10 20 years might
become a real problem
now where the discussion we're having
now we're now facing
the result of that in the space of
viruses uh
like for many years avoiding the
conversations here
i don't know what to do that in the
early days
but i think we have to i guess create
institutions where people can stand out
people can stand out and like basically
be
individual thinkers and break out into
all kinds of
spaces of ideas that allow us to think
freely
freedom of thought and maybe that
requires a decentralization of
institutions
well years ago i came up with a concept
called cultivated insecurity and the
idea is
let's just take the example of the
average joe
right the average joe has a job
somewhere
and their mortgage their
medical insurance their retirement
their connection with the economy is
to one degree or another dependent on
their relationship
with the employer that means that there
is
a strong incentive especially in any
industry where it's not easy to move
from one employer to the next there's a
strong incentive
to stay in your employer's good graces
right so it creates a very top-down
dynamic not only
in terms of who gets to tell
other people what to do but it really
comes down to
who gets to tell other people how to
think so that's extremely dangerous
the way out of it is to cultivate
security to the extent that somebody is
in a position
to go against the grain and have it not
be a catastrophe for their family
and their ability to earn you will see
that behavior a lot more so
i would argue that some of what you're
talking about is just a simple
uh predictable consequence of the
concentration
of the the sources of well-being
and that this is a solvable problem
you